ah we are back great to be back into it
with the waterlad season three it was
cool to get away from it all for a
little bit but i did miss bringing you
some of the stories of some of the
biggest lads around and i'm really
pumped for season three just to see
where we end up
but i'm also very grateful to have some
very loyal sponsors recommit for season
three firstly pure sports cbd i had so
many messages last year from people
saying how much this product helped
their quality of life especially people
with sore joints so i love getting
messages like that it really is cool to
hear and if you want to give it a try
head over to water.com where you can
find out all the information on how you
can get 20 percent off also pomeroy's
coffee they're continuing to support
this podcast and this season they're
offering listeners a special discount of
20 off any coffee or tea and they have
some unreal stuff on their website so
make sure you head over to wallet.com
again and all the information is on
there how you can get 20 off but thanks
again for tuning in looking forward to
season three and if you enjoy this
episode please give it a share it's very
much appreciated all right let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh what a lad so just like the start of
every season the first guest is no doubt
the most important just to set the tone
for the year and honestly if i could
choose one person on this whole entire
planet it would be this man who i have
with me today he's one of the biggest
lads in the world and on top of that
he's also had a very inspiring rugby
story which has seen him dominate for
teams including the tasman marco the
crusaders and now on the world stage
where he belongs with the all blacks he
is of course one of the greatest lads in
the game it is the great ethan
blackadder welcome mate cheers pleasure
to be here man and it's um exciting to
be on the party with you mate so
grateful to have you even come out to
the studio out to the shed
a man who i've had so many requests to
get on at least three messages a day
when is ethan coming on
what are they thinking
but you're not even on social media are
you so you stay well away from that any
reason behind that
yeah i
got rid of it a couple years ago off
facebook and the instagram yeah um yeah
wasted a bit too much time on all that
and i thought i'll pull trigger and get
it out of my life and um yeah haven't
looked back good good decision i feel
yeah you wouldn't look to go back in
there uh probably not no no i think i've
done my dash
oh mate that's good stuff but anyway
this year what a year last year was for
you such an incredible year for you
personally how do you look back on that
yeah oh i was unreal really
thinking back to the start of it just
like the uh pre-season grind and then
you set your goals early january of what
you want to go out and achieve and then
you just sort of go from there and chip
away at it and have a lot of fun doing
it so yeah it was a heck of a year i
loved it mate and a hell of a rise
finishing with the all black tour how
was that one yeah one of the one of the
best tours i've been on heck of a lot of
learnings and
a lot of fun too on and off the field
and
yeah to play international rugby was
yeah something very special so we you
came from tasman obviously where you
were injured the year before and to fast
forward a year
um you're now established all black um
must have been an unreal journey
yeah that's right so yeah thinking back
to 2020 and getting through that knee
injury and yeah had a lot of fun doing
that too i i enjoy
the injury side of things just the work
you put in to get back to the the
ability to go and play so
yeah heck of a heck of a fun journey and
to get back out there and
wave is yeah makes it worth it your
mindset around injuries i love hearing
that because so many guys aren't like
that they get so um down when they get
injured but you genuinely enjoy it and
you had an opportunity last year to
probably just stay down in christchurch
and and do your own rehab but you still
came up to tasman you're filming all the
trainings helping out all the guys so
just a massive difference in your
mindset yeah that's right um i had a
have had a couple injuries over the
years nothing like nothing that rules
you out for sort of more than six months
so
yeah from the first one i just got stuck
into the the process of it i enjoyed
that so the wee steps at a time the um
improvements you slowly make and yeah i
just love today like i genuinely enjoyed
the whole injury process and when you
get back for your first game i just you
look back and go i love that experience
so how did you get that mindset because
it's so i feel like it's so unique and
such a cool mindset to have and one that
could be so powerful for so many players
yeah i don't know to be honest i think
just
yeah i like working hard and with
injuries you've got to work hard and
you've got to put the time in and you've
got to do a lot of listening to
your
physios and doctors and
just trusting is a massive thing over
there but um yeah i don't think there's
any secret ingredient but yeah if i'm
not playing and i'm
trying to fix myself to get playing all
my times going into that and then
obviously you're all black being called
into the all blacks how did you find
initially being named and then the week
in the camp yeah it was obviously a
pretty um
yeah strange week actually i
yeah i was um just at home with my
flatmate i knew the naming was at night
but i didn't i didn't want to watch it
or anything did you think you're a
chance
i had a couple people in the weeks that
are saying good luck with it yeah sort
of it was a weird feeling because you
just sort of like
yeah is this a possibility or what have
you but
yeah i didn't want to watch it i was i
was playing a bit of xbox
and he um
yeah he wanted to put it on i just said
no i'm just going to watch yeah mom plan
yeah call of duty so
and then he um yeah he had on audio on
his phone and yeah he heard my name and
then that's how i found out
and then yeah the phone went berserk
yeah
all the support messages and stuff so
yeah yeah it was pretty unreal to be
fair
crazy and then going into the
environment yeah it was real kauai
because
didn't really yeah don't really know
what to expect you know and um once you
get there yeah all the staff and all the
players that you've um played against
and then all of a sudden you're joining
up as a team and all very welcoming and
yeah it was real kawaii real cool
experience and you made you
made yourself welcome pretty quickly by
breaking body's nose
yeah they got they actually got that
wrong it didn't actually happen at
training oh was
he got to his feet and i come in from
the side to um have a crack at the ball
oh true i got cleaned out and my elbow
drove straight up his snout
[Laughter]
oh that's classic when i heard it was it
training i was like there's classic
doofy going going hard as he always does
yeah that's the thing no surprises
yeah there was several other incidents
to that throughout the year
so what is your mindset when you're
training like that because you you do
always give it give it everything and is
that just something you've always done
yeah you get told from time to time just
sort of
chill out and stuff
but um yeah i've been trying to work on
that over the last couple years and
sometimes your natural instincts
take over but um
yeah
as they say that classic sort of handy
training but um yeah i'm i've i'm
putting some work into it to try and
dumb it down
i think it's the thing sometimes you get
for me i gotta sorta go hard at
something to get it right i can't go
through the motions
and get it right but um
then it comes into mental reps and
a bit of stuff away so you don't have to
necessarily
be burning gas when you don't need to
yeah and your first test match against
tonga yeah that was um pretty cool man
so got to the
got to the sheds and the team
announcement and
far out like i'm wearing the silver fern
this weekend yeah and then um so i was
off the bench that game and then you get
the nod from shandy to
come up yeah so yeah well this is
pretty exciting and the hacker how are
you
oh not too bad i don't think i need to
actually have a close review of that
do you get feedback on your haka or
anything or
how did you learn it who taught you or
did you already know it you kind of knew
it i actually uh jumped on youtube bull
crap yeah i jumped on youtube just to
get the sequence right so
it started off with
six slaps on the legs yeah i knew that
before you go up yeah and then it goes
two
yeah so i jumped on youtube did my
homework and then um yeah we just we did
some practice and stuff and because
obviously there's the two hackers yeah
but uh yeah a couple of times got a
little bit mixed up between the two at
certain times yeah yeah if the
opportunity comes again i've got some
work to do
and where your place and who decides
where you go is that uh
is that a call from someone higher above
yeah i don't know it just sort of falls
into place and then
there'll be a few people at the back and
then if if you don't get the back early
then you're in the middle in the pyramid
or
yeah yeah i ended up a couple of times
sort of four rows back oh yeah
but in the game as soon as you got the
call to go on make instant impact yeah
yeah the boys did a lot of damage
against tonga so i just went on and just
yeah just try to focus on my role and
just enjoy it yeah first game and the
black jersey yeah something like you
drove yeah you literally dream of so
yeah it was very cool and then a couple
of big games against um aussie in south
africa talk me through how those ones
compared and what that was like
yeah yeah i um ended up playing against
the wallabies in perth um already got an
early injury so i was on in the first
end of the first half
and yeah that was a pretty cool
atmosphere and
just to um yeah get on top of them and
get into our rhythm was yeah awesome and
we come out on top that game but yeah
definitely a step up from the tonga game
yeah and then the uh going into the
african games yeah that's another level
yeah that was a real good introduction
to
what international rugby is pretty much
yeah
and what was the difference what what's
the main difference for you
just like where you gotta mentally be
and physically where you need to get to
to compete at that level yeah that's
massive thing i um notice with
international rugby
there really is a different beast yeah
and um
small things matter big time i noticed
and key keys for you what around
discipline or contact area what's the
real focus is that you found like man
i've got to get up to speed here yeah
yeah definitely the contact area you
don't want those big african lads
getting roll-ons because that suits
their game so
like learnings they took out of those
games you got to stop them where they
are or drive them back and if they keep
getting roll-ons it's so tough to um
have a crack at the ball or get into
your d systems
but something you've always been very
good at is that stuffing people as they
come you've always had a really good
mindset into the tackle what is your
mindset going in
yeah you gotta um
it's something you always got to work on
too like a few years ago i put a lot of
effort into it um back at tasman and i
was getting some good pay out of it just
when i was reviewing games just from the
little um technical things i was working
on
and it's something you've got to always
for me i always got to keep doing it
because if you just stop sharpening the
toll you just lose a little bit of edge
yes that was a big learning actually
this year like you got to stay on top of
the little things and so you can um
be at your best in that area and mindset
wise mindset for that stuff you gotta
you gotta want to dodo you gotta love
doing it
and you love it
yeah no i don't enjoy it and
definitely love it and does as injuries
ever put you off i was talking to liam
squire about this not that long ago but
i mean his mindset was pretty similar
and you guys were you guys are pretty
similar players both very reckless
regard for your body but um talked about
his whole mindset going in absolute no
fear you're the same do injuries come
into play like once you've had a couple
of injuries do you start fearing for
your body going into these tackles or is
that never even come into your mind
uh no it doesn't come into mind really
yeah because i think if you were if you
were worried about an injury you're
gonna be
you're gonna be half-assed i feel yeah
and it would be noticeable if it was
like that i think
so yeah i think
build the body up get it resilient and
then so you can 100 confidence yeah
confidence i reckon it's crucial and
then going over to the uk how did that
style of rugby compared to those
africans and australian sides
yeah it was quite a different style like
we um we kicked off against wales oh
sorry they the usa game and the boys um
put on a clinic there
went into the wales game and um yeah it
was quite quite different a like
just probably the directness of play
yeah
and they they like to hold the ball for
long phases and
try and get on top of you and break you
down um
yeah yeah it definitely was different
and a couple of losses obviously to the
back end of the year there with ireland
and france how did how did you feel the
team handled those
yeah we um
yeah went into the island game and that
was a it was a pretty brutal contest we
yeah didn't come out on top on that game
but took away some good stuff and
she has a pretty good review good honest
review yeah yeah and it was um obviously
only a week to
get a few things right for that france
game so
quickly have a hard look at
the it yourselves and at the team and
then you move on and get ready for that
french test and
yeah that was another pretty brutal one
eh
it was um i didn't play that game i was
watching and
yeah they really um took it to us but
there's a lot of good fight back i feel
yeah yeah just the first half was
damaging
and you must look back and be pretty
proud of your season you played a lot of
good minutes a lot of good footy for the
all blacks what how do you feel you went
personally
um yeah no i r yeah really enjoyed the
opportunities i got having great players
around to help as well was
massive
but um yeah i feel i took a good
stepping stone of where i want to get to
but um yeah and it never stops you know
yeah that's uh i've wrapped this page
out it's a clean page heading into 2022
and that's what excites me
oh that excites everyone what a year
yeah so i'll look back in time but um i
just love 2021 it was awesome enjoyable
season of footy so
yeah right before we get too far i'm
pretty keen to hear about how these big
superstars
grow up and what their life was like as
a young fella
obviously you're dead all black
what was what was your childhood like
yeah right we'll start from the
beginning
born in rangyura just north of
christchurch people call it rangoon
[Laughter]
that's how it's known um i lived there
until i was about yeah seven years old
yeah yeah just an um
yeah not far from the city centre
that i'm uh schooling there for a bit
and um dad took up a job in scotland
yeah playing for the uh edinburgh
gunners
so um jetted off over there for one year
yes i lived and lived in edinburgh with
my mom and my sister and yeah and dad
and um i come back after a year
i went to golden bay oh sure and i
actually live with my grandparents there
and did everyone else stay over there uh
i mean sorry maybe my sister come back
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i didn't stay
over in edinburgh so i didn't enjoy it
or yeah i think so i think yeah yeah but
a homesickness and yeah um
wasn't much grass there
being an active person or a cat at the
time yeah you wanted to get outside and
it was just yeah different uh world over
there yeah how did you find like going
to school and stuff over there
i don't have a lot of memories of it but
i have certain sort of memories it's
like yeah massive buildings um
a lot of flight stairs yeah
but yeah that's i don't remember too
much yeah all i remember is there was no
grass at the school
filthy see it came home and um yeah i
got lollies before every morning before
i went to school oh sure there was a
highlight
where you from
yeah probably didn't help me
so it must have been hard for your mum
and dad to stay in scotland and let you
guys come back home was it
uh yeah i actually haven't asked that
question but uh yeah yeah all i knew was
um yeah dad was playing and then he
didn't long after he went into coaching
yeah
yeah so um yeah i was back in nz and
just going to primary school and doing
all that stuff mate collingwood there's
plenty of grass over there how did you
find living there yeah yeah it was it
was awesome i i went to collingwood area
school for one year yeah and um love
with my grandparents it was awesome good
time and then uh
back to christchurch after after a year
for just one more year in christchurch
had your parents move back by then no so
um dad was still over in scotland oh
yeah and then i was in christchurch at
home there because mum had come home
yeah yeah and then um yeah dad took up a
job at the tasman rugby union so that's
when i made the move
oh true oh that's crazy yeah yeah and
when your dad moved back were you guys
out in collingwood ah no no no you enter
in town yeah yeah and nelson and stoke
there so
and is that when you started going to
nelson college
exactly that yeah i went to
prep school from year seven and i went
yeah ended up going right through to
year 13. one thing that everyone like
one thing i'm really interested to hear
about is
how you went from because you didn't
really play rugby did you you you
weren't really into it coming through
the age grades yeah yes and no i i
played a little bit of junior footy yeah
like um i played my junior rugby for
stoke from under 12s to 13s
and then
a little bit a couple games under four
teams yeah and then that that was pretty
much it from there until
other seventh form my last year at
school
yeah i wasn't i didn't enjoy my rugby i
had a lot of hobbies and i like getting
it outdoors and stuff and at the time i
didn't enjoy the game of rugby at all
yeah why was that is it anything to do
with your old man playing and being a
all black captain or is it any
any real reason that you can put it down
to why you weren't enjoying it yeah like
a little bit of pressure actually yeah
definitely a little bit of pressure
there and um yeah i just i just
had to sort of get away from it yeah
yeah and that was my my exit yeah
so is that people comparing you to your
old man or saying oh you're going to be
all black and all this sort of pressure
was it
yeah little things like that like um
yeah little comments here and there and
stuff i i just couldn't deal with it at
the time yeah so because i couldn't do
that it's like well i'm not i'm not
starting involved in something i don't
like yeah so yeah i just i got away from
it and it was the best thing i did yeah
at the time and what did you get into i
was into yeah a lot of yeah outdoors a
lot of meat harvesting and fishing and
motorbiking motocross and stuff like
that
yeah so i had heaps of hobbies that i
love doing so
that was the main thing and how did you
go at school
school was um yeah it was i love nelson
college i couldn't speak more highly of
it yeah i
yeah it was probably
year eight uh
year eleven was a bit of a wake-up call
always a few detentions here and there
and being disruptive in class and
all that i learned a lot at school and
um i'm thankful for what they put up
with at times yeah but um you got to
year 12 and 13 and
started a lot of subjects you can do at
uh nelson so a lot i really enjoyed that
and um probably put my head down at
times but um a heck of a heck of a time
at school did you do any other sports
you obviously weren't doing rugby you
weren't in the first 15 did you do any
other sports that you were playing i was
playing yeah cracker oh yes i actually
really enjoyed my cricket i played that
right through school actually oh yeah
every summer how'd you go better bowler
uh better i worked my way from sort of
11 to 10 got up to fourth
third fourth better at some stage
towards the end there and i used to do a
bit of keeping oh yeah well they need to
get you in that black clash and get you
out there man i'd love to see you around
there at number three or four oh crying
they they can wrap it in some of those
guys those ex black hats oh yeah
yeah so oh true so cricket but there was
never you were never really looking to
go down that career were you cricket nah
i just played it because i loved it at
the time i really enjoyed it and that's
pretty much what you've done with
everything right you've only done the
things that you love doing and um it was
the same with rugby
yeah exactly that yeah i i just find
it's hard to motivate myself if i don't
like something yeah yeah so that was an
easy influencer so then how did the love
for rugby come back
um yeah right so we got to year 13 at
school and then a lot of my mates were
playing sort of third 15 and stuff yeah
and um i was ah might as well go and
have a game and then just had a couple
games and
yeah it was a lot of fun like there's no
pressure yeah yeah there's no pressure
you just go out and play off the lads
so i played uh five or six games i think
sort of half a season were you good
uh i i can't really tell i
yeah i'd have to ask my mates but
no i just i was just enjoying i was
pretty small yeah i um
probably 85 dropping weight
yeah
not much to me back then
um yes i just did that and then out of
school
once school had all finished up i so a
lot of those same friends were um
we're keen to play senior bees for
nelson yeah
yeah so then we um
we cracked them into that same sort of
friend group so yeah yeah
yeah sort of all skyrocketed from there
really crazy so when did you start
thinking well i'm loving this so much
that i might turn it into a profession
or when did you think man i'm actually
quite good at this how did you go from
playing in the b comp in nelson to being
an all black
crazy um yeah i played that senior b
yeah back in 2013 and just had an
absolute ball on and off the field we um
yeah we just played because we
we loved it yeah we loved the um beers
after the game and we're in town every
weekend
little rock it was batman
oh you would have caused some damage
yeah so um that was yeah massive and
then the next year oh but no sorry
nelson bay's under 18's come in that
season oh yeah yeah so i played that and
we went to south islands and stuff like
that and um
yeah and then the next season rolled
around and i was oh i'm going to have a
crack at seniors
so then um had a crack at seniors i
played about five six games that year
and got an injury but i was fortunate
enough at the time tony lewis who old
ceo of tasman yeah he um
gave me a call and asked if i'd like to
join the academy back then
and that's sort of the first sort of
stepping point for me so i joined the
academy and the hp group what it was
back then and um
yeah then i was sort of an um out of
tasman system true so that's when you
started to think this could actually be
a thing
exactly that yeah that's when i thought
um because i always loved the marcos
even though i wasn't um playing at
school with marcos with the team yeah i
always used to watch them back in the
boarding house yeah davey and all that
all the legends yeah yeah that was
pretty much that sort of got me on track
really and then once you got in there
right like you've already sort of
mentioned once you're in you're all in
so you
you knuckled down and you had pretty um
quick growth didn't you
yeah so um joined 2014 and um
was in the academy for a couple years
yeah
yeah had a few um few niggles then so i
didn't actually get a lot of rugby in
until um
2016
club season and um got a full year of
footy in
minimal injuries and um that was the
first year i got called into
the godfather andrew goodman
and uh rangy leon how did that
conversation go yeah it was very
very cool i'll never forget that one
yeah it was one of the coolest moments i
getting told you'll um
be on the pudc for the season
yeah that was it was very cool and what
was your debut like
we went down to otago
and i got on i was come off the bench
that game
and i got on for the last 25 minutes
yeah and yeah that was that was awesome
fun
time just yeah yeah exactly just rapping
and
yeah putting the tasm jersey on for the
first time you know at all did you
always feel confident you were up to
that level like because you had such a
unique pathway did you ever feel like
you weren't going to be good enough or
did you always were you always confident
in your own ability
that's a great question and the answer
to that is no yeah i actually a lot of
especially early on
did questions am i am i good enough to
be out here yeah fully yeah
yeah and that doesn't help with
confidence either if you've got your
inner voice telling you you shouldn't be
out here and stuff like that yeah it's
quite hard to be confident yeah so yeah
that took a couple of um a couple of
seasons
to sort of shake that monkey off and
just think that the coaches have picked
you here so it doesn't matter what
everyone else or what you're saying to
yourself you've got to back yourself and
um do it for them as well you know
and your ability to be a team man you
win you've won marco man you've won the
crusaders
man of the year whatever it is but mate
your ability to be a team man off the
field is so
such a big part of especially the tasman
marker i'm sure it is down at the
crusader as well and hearing from the
all black boys you've instantly made an
impact in their environment as well so
have you learnt that attitude to just
always put the team first because i know
you genuinely do
um
yeah it's always been a driver team
first because the team's definitely
bigger than the individual so i think if
you
if you're giving and doing the right
things
for the team then um
yeah it's just always a mindset team
first and if you install that in
yourself it just comes out i suppose i
mean a lot of guys say it and they feel
like they know it but you literally live
by that more than anyone i've seen like
you're always doing the little things
around the team environment like i said
before when you're injured you come up
and you're filming every day for the
boys or trying to help everyone out as
much as you can
yeah yeah like i
i wouldn't even question not doing that
you know yeah yeah but um yeah it's just
it's the lads and the team and the
people around you and the teams why you
do it you know like the team's
unreal like it doesn't feel like work at
all yeah it's just a lot of fun and um
you're doing it with your mates so i'm
gonna just make the most of it and then
enjoy
all the time i've got doing it really
and was your dad much of an influence on
your rugby career through that sort of
period um no not like
because early on i didn't play much
rugby and then um
he's always been a great influencer for
me as a fatherly figure you know yeah
yeah and he's supported me from day. so
um yeah he's definitely helped me a lot
really because he um he's played a lot
of rugby and
done a lot of coaching and he's been
around so um yeah he's definitely helped
me over the years for sure so are you
constantly in contact with him does he
give you feedback on your game how does
how does that relationship sort of work
um we've sort of got the relationship
we're just like good mates yeah even
though he's my dad yeah yeah we're just
real good mates and um
we don't talk too much in depth about
footy yeah and i think that it's
probably yeah that's healthy yeah but oh
we we have all sorts of conversations
and yeah talk about all sorts but yeah
from time to time definitely would you
ever like to be coached by them
no i probably wouldn't
yeah
no i probably wouldn't
but
i've been years ago i come and um
trained with the crusaders for a week
when i was still coaching oh yeah that
was fine but how old were you then uh it
would have been
20
21 oh true yeah back in 2016. sure
yeah
so so going back to the tasman marco uh
the 2019 year probably caps it off for
you as one of the standout memories you
guys had a stack loose ford trio you
guys worked really well together what
are your memories from that yeah
yeah that yeah we'll um never leave the
memory banks ever yeah it was um one of
the best most enjoyable experiences i've
ever had in a team yeah
yeah we um we had an awesome bunch of
lads and that's right for all the
players staff
everyone
and we um we just had a real good vision
and a theme
that we wanted to turn around after a
couple of um
years making finals and missing out
and um yeah we we cracked into it from
round one and um yeah we had a lot of
quality players that
definitely probably should have been
higher on us but
thankfully we had them for that year and
that was a mess of um help as well in
terms of leadership and the way they
played the game but um yeah we we
cracked in had a lot of fun
on and off the field we had some
absolute characters
had a lot of laughs and um
yeah overall it was yeah one of the
greatest and winning the final was
probably your first final that you'd won
uh what was that feeling like
yeah that was um surreal i'll never
forget that one i was um on the sideline
just busted my shoulder the week before
and the semi
against auckland so i was um i set out
for that one watched the boys put a lot
of work in and when will jordan got that
uh run away off
next break yeah and score that sort of
near yeah pretty sealed up yeah and then
when that final whistle went where you
all just charged on went berserk it was
one of the best moments so
and you always go pretty gonna do as
well so what was the next few days like
that was a huge do that was one of the
biggest
i remember that the start of it and the
hangover forever
so yeah straight to the
walker that night and then the next day
we're back to where it happened on fargo
park oh yeah
and then we're going thank the sponsors
and the ladies in the kitchen
out at the uh turf
and then uh the sands bar
oh yeah what day are we up to here we're
up to uh so
yeah day three yeah it was the sands bar
yeah and then rolled through that night
and early morning to
the uh golf day
did you get along to the candle hole i
didn't actually make it to the counter
hole that day that year
which i was pretty devastated about
because that was
it looked loose
[Laughter]
oh that's so good and uh obviously even
last year when um you weren't playing
you're a big part of the non-23 do um
you brought a lot of energy to that
group and i think you were the mvp of
that
that piss up as well
that was awesome led by yourself awesome
organisation lawn bowls
and then uh back to our awards night 923
awards night yeah and then i took the
walker to watch the boys do the job and
it was unbelievable as well great that
was so cool watching that fine away
everyone was right in one but
that game was so intense and mate when
when davey got over that ball and got
that turnover the eruption at the walker
was just next level away tables rattling
glasses smashing
shirts off it was gone that was large
and then obviously when uh red got that
ball off that quantity won the ball in
the air and got it off the back of the
mall that was just
we knew from there
so good such good times
and even the next few days you were
still as impressive as always
that was up there for yeah it was a
massive do and we had a lot of fun and
just tops it always tops off like a fun
year i think yeah into your season
functions yeah there's always some good
memories to be made uh yeah
but going back a little bit um we've
sort of gone past your crusaders but um
your crusaders debut in the first time
you got called into the crusaders uh
what was that like did you have any
other teams who were looking to get your
signature as well
uh going back to the very start of that
um no there wasn't much hadn't heard
anything through the 2017
season with the marco yeah i um got to
wear the final and christchurch against
canterbury and come short yeah somewhere
story we're on to do
[Laughter]
we're on a we're on a doe at the turf on
a sunday thanking the sponsors and the
ladies in the kitchen
and then um i actually got a phone call
from jace ryan oh yeah yeah so that that
come through and um
yeah he told me he said um we packed you
for the 2018 crusader squad that's
you know i was i was over the moon that
was it was unbelievable yeah and because
you growing up you had always been a
crusaders fan that was always probably
the team of your choice definitely i
used to watch the crusaders from
year back in the early days of school
i used to get up early mornings watch
them when they're in africa yeah yeah
i've always been a huge fan of the
crusaders and
to think i was into christchurch was
yeah awesome it's cool that you've got
to play for the all the teams that
you've loved growing up the marco the
crusaders and the all blacks yeah that's
right exactly that like you couldn't i
couldn't have scrapped it better really
like my favorite teams i've ended up
being fortunate to wear the jersey for
so it makes it that much more special
yeah and what was it like going in there
obviously when people go first make the
super rugby squads i guess they see a
lot of guys who they're pretty
starstruck about but what was it like
for you
yeah i was i was pretty nervous to be
fair yeah definitely nervous on that day
one um flew down to christchurch and
they do the bit of a photo shoot and a
lot of media and stuff what were you
like with media and
photo shoots natural or how do you find
it oh at first i was yeah but definitely
out the comfort zone yeah yeah i knew
what questions were coming and yeah it
was just sort of yeah pretty nervous
in the modeling
i could imagine you'd love being in
front of the camera oh not so much
hard to get a grunt out of me back then
but all the boys mate would have made
you feel welcome yeah yeah the crusaders
environment's very special also yeah
welcome from day dot that's all the
players staff as well they are
well oiled machine the crusaders and
yeah it's a pleasure rocking up there
every day to
play the game and what was your
crusaders debut like sun walls was that
that's exactly it you've got your stats
bang on hey i remember it like it was
yesterday oh i loved watching big each
and black edit run out there for his
debut
yeah 2018 rainy night
yeah i got the um the nod to
uh start actually yeah yeah that was
very cool in the sixth jersey it was i
remember from that night how yeah the
game finished and then i thought yeah
this is quite different to what i've
played yeah i just noticed like everyone
just had to just do their job oh that's
one thing i took out of that game
thinking back on it yeah just everyone
just does their job and a lot of it
unfolds off that but um did you almost
find it easier than what you played
previously or because it was just doing
your role
yeah possibly
um every game of footy's pretty tough
like yeah generally pretty sore after
yeah but yeah i think and structure and
stuff definitely
because um there's a lot of good players
around and they make you they force you
and get to try and get you better yeah
yeah that was an awesome experience you
get your
get your number and stuff like that
for the pull room and you made an
instant impact obviously you got i think
you won rookie of the year that year as
well um obviously the crusaders enjoyed
having on their books
yeah yeah i did um pick up that award um
fortunately yeah that was it was an
awesome year to look back on and you see
the names on that trophy and you think
why
should i
be definitely should mate and any other
games or seasons that stand out for you
in the crusaders career so far uh yeah
definitely um for me yeah 2021
i um
strung some consistent games together
and we worked away and um took out the
aotearoa comp so yeah probably fresh off
that definitely last season because the
years before you were out with a few
injuries too weren't yeah
yeah yeah a few few niggles and stuff
like that and let's not decide and enjoy
those uh that those seasons no you love
being injured it was just like um
yeah the development and the learning
yeah that was the massive thing because
uh back then there was like
jordan tafora and karen reed and matt
todd you know all those
high level great players and you can
just sort of sponge and just watch what
they do observe
crazy so cool to hear how you've
transitioned and so quickly as well so
um then obviously a massive year last
year 2021 you get your call for the all
blacks
and now yeah now you're on your way yeah
it's crazy to yeah think how quickly in
a season it can progress really but um
just loving it and your work rate was
one thing that i've wanted to sort of
mention because mate you
you put in so much work in a in a game
you never stop i've never seen you walk
on a field how how do you push yourself
mentally to keep on going um yeah it's
sort of it's probably natural for me
i've always um
i've always sort of done that yeah yeah
it's it started from a young age i used
to do a lot of fitness and
a lot of mountain biking when i was
younger yeah
what if what you're doing your fitness
for was it just to keep fit or yeah
training for anything in particular it
was a lot of it was actually the
challenge yeah yeah to keep fat as one
but the challenge i used to love
mountain biking and i'd push myself real
hard
a couple of times a week with a good old
friend pete we used to go out all the
time yeah
and yeah i think a lot of it stemmed
from that just fitness at a young age
enjoyed
enjoyed the grind and then
i think that translated well for me
going forward
because that's sort of that's what i
knew at the time and i knew working hard
helps yeah
now you look like you enjoy the grind
you look like you're enjoying it when
you're hurting yeah yeah you gotta you
gotta put a smile on your face
it's tough everyone's hurting yeah so
yeah data it is it's enjoyable are you
the same when you're in the gym and
stuff when you're doing like a what bike
session is that are you enjoying that
you enjoy pushing yourself mentally like
that
yeah you do it's always like uh
yeah a challenge and you're doing it for
the for the right reason really yeah
trying to get better and get fitter and
yeah it's all working towards the common
goal i feel and when you've got a skill
to work on or this is
what goodies been telling me if they
give you a work on mate you're
constantly working on i remember him
mentioning about your pass out the back
on a backdoor play
probably weren't that good at a couple
years ago now you're one of the best
fords out at the tip or the out the back
play just constantly working on skills
that you need to to get to that next
level
yeah that's exactly right like it just
that's what i'm very thankful for is the
players and coaches i've had around me
that can
just say hey just have a look at your
ball out the back
because i need you better yeah and then
straight away it just puts it i put it
on myself or i gotta get i gotta get
this right for the team yeah and then
yeah because there's a lot of there's so
many different details and
variables in in the gamer rugby yeah so
many different little skill sets so just
try and stay on top of them and get
better as
a constant mate i love that so what's
the next work on for you have you have
you got any more work ons or have you
nailed them all
no i'll never nail them all
no constantly working on them yeah but
yeah i break it down have a good review
at the end of the seasons and then um
look at a lot of things
one thing i have noticed is like a lot
of things is like you got to try and be
in the best body position
all the time
you'll notice like tackle ball carry or
what have you if you're in the best body
position it can go a long way so yeah
just trying to look at shapes and
how i can be way better in that city
area oh that's cool that's exciting yeah
you're going to be in all sorts of body
positions
and then this year yeah you've seen your
crusaders um squad what do you make of
your squad for this season
yeah it's um yeah pretty exciting
actually i can't remember how many
four or five new um debutantes yeah
pebbles come over from argentina to join
the team yeah what do you think of that
yeah no i um bummed into them in the gym
the other day
had a good yarn yeah he's a he's a nice
bloke and um he's excited oh yeah you
two are going to be distracted out there
together because he's a beast too
yeah i've um
seen him play a few games and played
against them and yeah he goes real good
yeah true how do you think he's going to
fit into the crusaders environment
i think he'll fit in absolutely fine oh
yeah i had a good yarn from the other
day and he's he's nice guys
and the boys will um always be welcoming
so he'll be or he'll be fine mate and
your backs obviously you've got all
blacks galore in your back line so yeah
we've got a yeah there's a lot of class
players and and all that but um
yeah we'll get into our work like we
always do and nothing's a given and
we'll look forward to this season and
what position do you see yourself
playing this season or going forward
even
um
yeah hard to say really i've i've played
most my career at blindside at number
six yeah
and then um
couple games at seven
and then had one at eight yeah but um
yeah it sort of it comes it literally
comes down to the coach because like you
can you can want something but
if that doesn't fit the purpose of the
team then it's
yeah it's not really on the same page so
yeah i will literally play wherever i'm
um wanted yeah but um yeah i've played
most of my career at six so that would
that be my preferred but i don't
actually mind and going forward any
plans have you looked much further ahead
than this year's crusader season
no no i never looked too too far ahead i
couldn't imagine you actually i've
always got my goals for the year and
then um yeah
yeah i'm just more worried about what's
happening
today later on with some field running
and what the weight looks like for
structure and balance
yeah short-term goals and focus on where
your feet are for me love that and what
about post footy i mean are you the same
in that with that area or yeah are you
looking that far ahead
no i haven't looked too far ahead i've
with my personal development and stuff i
i try to try and do different things um
i started off building when i left
school i did yeah i did that for three
and a half years and um
yeah i'd like to think i'll finish that
at some stage yeah
yeah not looking at that really at all
um is that something you would do uh
build is that something you'd look to
potentially oh yeah
it depends how rough the carcass is
but um
yeah possibly yeah yeah i'd definitely
have to work for a year to knock off the
um certificate yeah
just to get practically signed off so
yeah i'll
when that stage comes i'll look at it
but um yeah would you look to go down
the coaching route like here old man
no i wouldn't coach yeah nah i've um
never really i've got a lot of respect
and
whatnot for coaches for what they do and
stuff it's pretty intense and
yeah it can be full-on just from my
observations and no i just like playing
the game rugby i can't see myself um
coaching at all hey that's crazy because
yeah
i know other guys are always coming to
you for advice around tackle technique
and how to do things a little bit better
so i feel like you'd be such a good
coach naturally that's interesting to
hear that it just doesn't interest you
yeah it's i don't know
something would have to drastically
change
well you're still only young aren't you
you're only 26 and um
your career is just sort of taking off
now so
uh mate you've got a lot of rugby ahead
of you
yeah no i hope so because um
yeah i love planet so i want to keep
playing it you know yeah as your goal
always to start new zealand or would you
look to go overseas at some point
um yeah i don't know it depend on a lot
of things but uh at the moment yeah i
love plan footy in new zealand and
obviously with a bit of stuff overseas
with like a little bit of covert and
stuff
yeah i think there's no better country
to be playing the game at the moment for
me fair enough anyway as always we've
gone to our instagram for some questions
and like i said at the start i literally
get three or four messages a day asking
when
ethan blackhead is coming on so
the most requested guests of all time
has come up with a heap of questions
first question what's your best bronco
best bronco was 4 32 last year wow
humming yeah
i was guarded actually i wanted four 29
said yeah
uh yeah yeah 429 yeah will you do that
this year maybe uh i'll give it a crack
yeah definitely i might as well while
i'm young
[Laughter]
i was um
i was side by side with tom christie and
he's a fit bloke and he he took off he
got 430 flat oh and he was just just in
front of him he just had that what extra
gear did he or i reckon because i
imagine you would just be grinding away
from the start would you just grinding
through it i always try and tell myself
on the first fret just keep it at 55
seconds yeah it always ends up
49 48. i see you got it yeah but it's
not wise
yeah because you want to yeah
oh yeah there's no point saving yourself
but at the same time
if being economical can definitely help
oh i love it okay
how does he fend off all the woman and
play footy
yeah
i can only guess who's asked that
question that looks like a young kid
actually all right no i don't i don't
know the answer to that um
i suppose i'm pretty uncontactable i've
got a fax machine and
only reached by a seagull right now
so that probably answers that and
is there a reason why you got off social
media just too many dms from women no
nothing to do with that not at all
no
but um
yeah no i'm just enjoying living life
and um yeah that's all there is to it
really fair enough um is he gonna follow
his dad's footsteps and come to
edinburgh
would you ever look to play in edinburgh
obviously you hated it and you got
you're haunted from your childhood
probably though
[Laughter]
a lot of people a lot of lads in the um
all blacks talked about how court was
going to scotland yeah in edinburgh
murrayfield so i think it would be quite
cool to
check it out over there but it's too
it's too unknown really yeah i'd like to
see the place again but
a lot of things that have to line up you
know oh yeah 100
okay
next one from your good mate mike glash
what's your best off the mattress speed
what's that
that's good from him um
quick yarn uh back in 2017 and nelson
yeah um sound asleep pretty hungover
from the weekend
monday morning one and yeah one in the
morning i heard my truck start up
and i knew straight away someone was
flogging it really so
but delayed off the mattress my mattress
speed was slow
and i ended up running out the driveway
and my grass and being a couple meters
away from someone in my ute driving away
oh wow and ever since then lashy goes
mate you're off the mattress steve is
terrible you need to work on it so
[Music]
the very next day
they were timing me i was practicing
to see if i could get better at it but
yeah that's that's that young
what speed have you got it too you must
be pretty quick now i think it was about
because the door was shut yeah so we
tried it with the door open and the door
shut and i think it was sort of two and
a half three seconds wow that's what you
got it to my room was right sort of by
the main door yeah but um that's quick
because what was it the day you reckon
it was too slow my i couldn't process it
i was half asleep heard the truck start
and probably a couple seconds lying
there and that was the difference
between me getting on the deck or not
[Laughter]
what would you have done if you caught
the car well that's the thing that was
mentioned i think i would have just sat
on there and hoped they would have
pulled over oh yeah but i was i
one
was
in
morning
geez it's probably better that you
didn't get on i imagine if they just
floored it i know yeah it could have you
heard the tyres barking all the way down
the streets oh they they were fast and
flat out sure did you ever catch him or
get the car back or anything we got it
back seven that morning did you yeah
yeah it was abandoned upper on top of um
sublime coffee up on the hill there oh
yeah
yeah they just stole um
literally a cigarette lighter and that
was it just the will you put your plugs
in all right just ask for it eh yeah
yeah i would have definitely have
government
moral of the story is don't leave your
keys in your ignition at nighttime
probably fair enough too
oh that is a great yarn okay another one
from mike lash uh
if it's anything like that last one this
will be good um what was your morning
retro at the flat at library road
oh he's got oh yeah he's got a few got
his old lash um yeah so every morning um
when we were flatting i was living with
mike and dave david eagle stuff and uh
and dylan and every morning i'd be up
pretty early to go to work and
i got this real weird sort of yawn so
i'd wake up have a big stretch and a
yawn
and then that'll
that'll wake up to it every morning
and then i'll go in and crash and bang
chuckle my lunch in this chili bin
trying to put weight on back then you
see so
food was always high
and then i banged crash round guns i'd
start my yoot up 15 minutes prior to
leaving yeah so this is 6 30 in the
morning sort of funny so it's rattling
away outside the boys windows and
they had shocking sleeps for a whole
year
for buggers how loud was your yawn oh
give us one
[Laughter]
i don't know it's sort of like oh you
know when you stretch and you just gotta
you gotta let it out it's sort of like
that but it's exaggerated
[Laughter]
and the boys coughed it i still do it
now
go on
oh it's just
like but louder
was it deliberate to wake them up we
just did not care no i wasn't deliberate
that was just yeah i actually did it
without noticing until they kept saying
shut up oh i love that great yarn okay
why does he always wear um a pad with
strapping on your left arm every game
and training
ah that coming
yeah i got a bicep injury we um round
one yeah just got my arm caught between
a couple bodies and krushma
oh it's just like a big bone bruise and
every time you tackle it training or
whatever you just hit it and it blows up
again
so i got a guard made and
started wearing and then i took it off
for one training and heard it again so
ever since
yeah it gets sore so i just leave it on
that's the reason why right fair enough
okay next question we've got heaps of
questions like this it's a bit of a
thing going around on social media one
is uh is it true you created giraffes by
uppercutting a horse
um
how did he lose his virginity before his
dad that one came in twice
and
is it true that when chuck norris needs
your help he has you on speed dial for
backup so there's heaps of you're
obviously a bit of a trend with that
sort of thing at the moment where did
that all start i actually i don't know
it's it's it's bizarre it's sort of um i
don't see a lot of that's coming from um
social yeah i feel my mates um
screenshot it when they see it and send
it to me yeah yeah so i do see it that
way and i was i was barefoot i was like
what was going on here
yeah kind of yeah very funny actually
but um yeah it sort of baffled me to be
honest
yeah it's crazy so when you see sort of
stuff like that does that make you think
because if you went on back on social
media now your account would obviously
completely blow up you'd have a massive
following um could create all sorts of
opportunities down the track but i know
conrad smith did it as well just not
interested not part of me doesn't suit
my um personality and not get into it
yeah yeah i think that's yeah bang on
what you said there um
i've got nothing against social media
and all that yeah it's kind to them and
nice them to be saying that stuff or
whatever
but um yeah it does
it just doesn't suit me and
yeah i find the funny side to it
definitely i reckon it's yeah it's
pretty hilarious but um
yeah that's sort of that's me i just i
play the game for that yeah and i guess
i guess the whole point that you're not
on social media sort of adds to the
whole mystique of your character
yeah yeah a bit offline um
yeah suits me well actually
off the grid
okay um
now this one's from max your little
understudy best ever do story best ever
do story that's a great one because
there's so there's a lot of them yeah
and it's hard to piece them all together
how does it compare through the levels
obviously you started with nelson club
um then tasman like the
crusaders and the other all blacks how
does that is is there a constant theme
between them all or does it
get a bit looser the lower you go
um
they're all like a do's who do yeah but
probably the the looser dues i've had
has been at tasman even more so than
nelson club
we oh we have had some ah sorry yeah i
can't leave nelson out there we have had
some crackers and help some plateau
over the years
yeah that's well that's where i actually
had my first dough oh sure i could
imagine div too nelson club um when
you're playing for the lover that sport
like that um you have some pretty big
occasions i'd imagine yeah absolutely
like it was almost the start of a day
every weekend
[Music]
yeah too many dudes
yeah oh yeah i'll never forget the first
i ever went to with nelson yeah because
that was life i was like what does this
happen on a regular
how old were you 19.
yeah yeah about yeah exactly 1920 yeah
yeah that was the first one i went to
and ever from there nothing but love for
it
it really wraps the year off well
and what about going up to the all
blacks you might not even had one
yet have you or how does it sort of work
at that level
um yeah we all yeah always have a few
beers after like the last game as such
yeah and because that's the year done
you wrap it up accordingly and
yeah socialize and stuff with the boys
you've been working hard before yeah
but um yeah like this year we had to
travel off pretty early so it's not
really much time to
we weren't home you know so much time to
sit down and um
all that but um yeah definitely still
enjoyed each other's company after the
campaign finished no doubt okay next one
are you worried about going prematurely
grey
um i haven't got any grays yet so hot
yeah hopefully not but um oh i'm not not
scared of it it's going to happen at
some stage
that question should have been directed
at me um
talk us through your left foot a drop
goal this was one of the great clips oh
yeah we were just having a bit of a mini
team challenge at training yeah and um
i've kicked off both feet i used to kept
when i was younger practice off my left
and stuff and one of those work-ons you
were given and you just went back and
hammered it
yeah yeah i just um
yeah i'll do something different yeah
fake the ride and just put on the left
it was only 20 meters out so it's not
that bloody spectacular
where'd you back yourself in a game to
get in the pocket
yeah i've had a lash at club rugby heavy
f1 yeah got it nah i missed that it was
a it was a worm burner
we had advantage right out in front and
i called for the ball and i just had a
lash
way off what about for the crusaders or
caesar would you fancy it
i think it would depend on the
circumstances of the game and if you had
advantage yeah possibly with advantage
you would maybe yeah with advantage on
the right
right part of the power
around where mitch hunt kicked his
famous one
45 out oh
i'd have to hit it sweet
but you prefer off your right foot right
foot's your first choice i s yeah right
it's what i've always kicked with and
then i just practice heaps off my left i
used to like when i was about 10 or 11
or when it was i used to just practice
goal kicking and kicking
so that was sort of why i did it and
then um
yeah just do it now and then but yeah i
learned i was kicking with um davey and
red over in um italy yeah and they were
just doing their kicks as you do his
back yeah and i was thumping them back
trying to hit the ball pretty well and
then i pulled up a sore quad i was like
what's going on and i was like i said to
davey i was like do you guys have to
like prime your legs for cacking he's
like yeah we do it all the time yeah i
can see why
i feel like i can't walk
so it's the end of the kicking kicking
yeah it's done
oh that's good stuff okay
um what is the best and worst part of
being the best looking man to ever play
the game
jeepers i don't know about you you've
got a lot of fans a lot of women fans as
well
oh cheapest i don't know i disagree yeah
we got to say we got a lot of these
questions when will jordan came on as
well very different
um comparisons obviously will's probably
a bit more of the pretty boy
but you make the more rugged um guy who
checks just love
yeah that baffles me to be honest
okay next one um what's the best brand
of forklift
or best forky it'd have to be the toyota
uh i can't remember the digits on the
end of it i uh drove a toyota farmlands
on the fawkey for a couple years yeah
just smooth airs how's that yeah the
actions are that good
and she'll go all day geez you should be
an ambassador for the toyota forklift
hey
surely that's the dream sponsorship for
you
yeah i'd i'd happily do it they they
work and they just keep going so nah it
was suits yeah
yeah and i had a lot of fun on the four
key oh no yeah okay
if you could pick a theme song for your
life what would it be
wow that's a great one
i like a lot of music um
[Music]
cheapest uh maybe
tom petty running down a dream oh wow
um
[Music]
or
oh i'm a cowboy oh yeah yeah nice yeah
one of them maybe but old squares but a
couple of great options yeah and what's
your go-to karaoke song i know you've
got quite a good voice as well oh
uh go to karaoke i got a heap of new
music this year because i was on a music
committee for a few years
so that's a tough game i had to go
reaching into
the depths of what i could find yeah
um probably
probably going to ever one eye i feel
like an airborne remix goes good in most
settings because you get the older crowd
that know it and then the remix with the
younger yeah every mix for me
you'll love it
okay this one uh how'd you get the
nickname doofy this is a good one i
don't actually know this one this one
stemmed from back at boarding school at
nelson college yeah um
one of the lads at the time his name was
chad we're in the
you're just outside of the dorms one day
yeah
and he's like oh you know what you're
like you're gollum smeagle or doofy
[Laughter]
like for a nickname and i was oh yeah
and then they're like no you're you're a
doofy
and it honestly went from there so back
in um when i was 14 or 13. oh great yeah
that's how it's cracker
yeah that's how it stems so it's been
around for with me for a while well we
um but have you changed your nickname to
scratcher or is that where's this one
come from
that's the probably the newest one i've
got now yeah and that'll um i've got a
yeah a good friend dan he's um from the
north island and he always used to say
to me like oh hey how you going shag
nasty
real funny ones like that and all sorts
of variations to that as well which i
won't mention
and then i just started saying
you're right shag scratched people oh
yeah and just yeah just random words and
then i was saying it too much and it i
got the name for it oh sure at the all
blacks you're calling guys scratch uh or
previous to that oh wasn't it yeah so i
used to call um scooter it and oh quinny
all sorts
yeah yeah it was just like g'day mate
that's what i used to say
and then bang it's labelled
now you're a scratcher are you more
commonly called scratcher or doofy uh
big scratcher now scratch it yeah that's
the most common one for me oh
interesting hey the life of the
nicknames okay last question
all the episodes have ended with this
one so
um best piece of advice ethan blackett
has for our listeners
around rugby or anything life rugby
whatever
you can you can choose yeah i've
probably said it a lot in here but i
think massive importance is just love
and enjoy what you do yeah and yeah so
you so like appreciate all the um the
friends and you
and your family because they are the
people that will um help you through the
highs and the lows or whatever so
yeah always sort of um
checking in for advice and
yeah just being being around good people
i think and then um
yeah probably just
be yourself and just short-term goal
settings i feel go a long way
yeah so just never
look too far ahead just focus on what's
happening tomorrow and now be in the
moment really i i feel
so um yeah yeah that's pretty much what
i i think mate that's so powerful i knew
you'd have such good advice hey you come
up absolute trumps
yeah that's um yeah been lucky over the
years to have a lot of good friends
around me i've learned a lot off and um
yeah definitely take a lot of their
stuff on board or try to anyway
well you do and that's that's the
difference i mean people can talk about
all these things but you actually live
it and you do it straight away so mate
it's been awesome to tap into your mind
over this last hour and get a feel for
what it's like to be inside that mind of
ethan blackhead
ah thank you man that's um it's been
cool to jump on it's been over a year
since it was mentioned
keep putting you off but um no it's been
awesome to come out and catch up mate
yeah mate well compared to where you
were a year ago to we are now even that
growth in that times been so massive and
looking forward to make watching your
growth over the next couple years as
well because
like we've talked about in this podcast
when you put your mind to something you
you just improve on it and your growth
is just so
um rapid that mate i'm so excited to see
where you get to in your career and
looking forward to following the journey
because matt you are one of the biggest
lads in the game so it's been awesome to
have you on what a lad cool thanks mate
heck of a lad and um awesome to catch up
so thank you very much you're a led
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you